♪ ♪
- GIVE ME A ROLL.
- WHICH ONE YOU WANT?
- GIVE ME BOTH OF THEM, MAN.
- OKAY.
- I'LL DECIDE WHICH ONE I WANT
WHEN I WANT TO EAT IT.
- MAYBE YOU WANT SOME
OF THESE VEGETABLES TOO?
- NAH, NAH.
- OKAY.
JUST SAYING, MAN.
THE NUTRIENTS IS GOOD FOR
MAINTAINING ENERGY LEVELS, SO...
- I KNOW WHAT THE FUCK
A VEGETABLE IS, MAN.
DON'T TELL ME
WHAT A VEGETABLE IS, MAN.
HEY.
I'M A GROWN-ASS MAN,
ALL RIGHT?
- MM-HMM. MM-HMM.
YEAH, I'M SORRY.
THIS THREE-BEAN SALAD
IS THE BOMB, THOUGH.
- OH, SNAP.
THEY GOT THREE-BEAN SALAD
UP IN THERE?
- MM-HMM.
- I DIDN'T EVEN SEE THAT.
- YOU WANT SOME OF MINE?
- YEAH.
- OKAY.
OPEN THE HANGAR.
- WHAT YOU DOING?
NUH-UH.
YOU DON'T DO THAT.
YOU DON'T FEED ME
LIKE A KID, MAN.
I'M A GROWN-ASS MAN.
- OKAY. YEAH, SURE.
YOU GOT SOME SCHMUTZ
RIGHT HERE.
- HEY, HEY, HEY, HEY!
GET OFF MY FACE, NIGGA!
YOU NEVER TOUCH
A GROWN MAN'S FACE!
- THAT'S RIGHT.
I'M SORRY, OKAY?
YOU ARE A GROWN-ASS--
- HEY, HEY, HEY!
I DON'T NEED YOU
TO PAT MY BACK!
I'M A GROWN-ASS MAN!
WHAT YOU DOING?
- I KNOW YOU'RE A GROWN--
I DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT ANYMORE
ABOUT GROWN-ASS MAN.
- THAT'S WHAT I AM.
- I DON'T WANT TO HEAR IT--
- WHY YOU HAVE TO TREAT ME--
- SHH. SHH.
- YOU'RE TREATING ME
LIKE A KID.
- THIS IS NOT THE PLACE
FOR THIS KIND OF--
- [whimpering]
- DON'T START ACTING UP AGAIN.
- 'CAUSE YOU'RE MAKING ME ANGRY.
- OKAY.
THEN I NEED YOU
TO BREATHE A LITTLE BIT.
CAN YOU BREATHE?
- [sniffling, exhaling deeply]
- TAKE A BREATH.
JUST BREATHE.
- DON'T YOU TELL ME
HOW TO BREATHE.
- NO, NIGGA,
I WANT A MOTHERFUCKING
INSIDE VOICE UP IN THIS BITCH.
DON'T BE GETTING LOUD
UP AROUND THESE WHITE PEOPLE.
- YOU TREAT ME LIKE A BABY,
BUT I'M NOT A BABY.
- ARE YOU NOT A BABY?
- I'M NOT A BABY.
- WHO PEE-PEED THEIRSELF?
- [crying]
- WHO LEFT THE PEE-PEE, HUH?
- I PEE-PEED.
- DID YOU PEE-PEE YOURSELF?
- JUST A LITTLE BIT.
- OKAY, THEN LET'S GO TO
THE BATHROOM AND CHANGE, OKAY?
- I DON'T WANT TO CHANGE.
- YOU GOT TO CHANGE.
- GET YOUR HANDS OFF OF ME!
- IS THAT HOW WE BEHAVE?
- [whining]
- STUPID BITCH!
- [gasps]
OH!
OH, I'M SORRY.
I'M SORRY.
YOU A GROWN-ASS MAN.
- [crying]
- ARE YOU A--
WHO'S A GROWN-ASS MAN?
YOU A GROWN-ASS MAN. OKAY?
- I AM.
- YOU A GROWN-ASS MAN, RIGHT?
- AND YOU KNOW
WHAT GROWN-ASS MEN DO?
YOU GO TO THE BATHROOM
AND CHANGE YOUR PANTS
WHEN YOU GOT
THE PEE-PEE, RIGHT?
- YEAH.
- YEAH? OKAY, LET'S GO.
LET'S GO, ALL RIGHT?
EXCUSE ME, EVERYBODY.
I'M SORRY, BUT MY SON GOT
THAT BENJAMIN BUTTON'S DISEASE.
UM, HE'S FOUR.
- 4 3/4.